la ministre nous ne sommes pas les
chiens ni des chiennes et nous ne
rentrerons pas la niche alors
de lutte que la lutte continue et vive
les casseroles
pardon je sais que vous avez pas le
temps mais ça va
d'habitude le rôle du ministre c'est de
rester assis à rien dire mais là c'est
pas possible cette phrase de Gérard
Philipe qui a été dite elle date de 1957
il y avait même pas de ministère de la
Culture à l'époque vous avez un
ministère qui a débloqué des aides
massifs pendant la crise pour vous
soutenir tous pour soutenir tous les
secteurs de la culture le 7 février on
avait une réunion vous avez demandé à la
reporter on la reporté au 16 mars vous
n'êtes pas venu vous avez demandé à la
reporter elle est reporter au 27 avril
c'est jeudi vous avez encore demandé à
l'annuler il est encore temps de changer
d'avis je suis là ma porte est ouverte
et bonne soirée à tous alors bon alors
là vous voyez là c'est quand là c'est la
première fois qu'une ministre donc
intervient comme ça c'est la première
fois qu'une ministre de la Culture
ose répondre lors d'une cérémonie mais
je vais vous racontais l'histoire et je
vous remercie challenge parce que ça va
sortir dans le challenge le jeudi vont
tout vous raconter exactement voilà dans
les détails de ce que je vais vous dire
là ce qu'on a vapeur vraiment les les
mêmes infos les deux artistes donc tu as
lu un communiqué de la CGT
ah super elles ont écrit leur truc tout
ça mais
on leur a dit on va vous mettre le texte
prompteur donc ils ont donné le texte
parce qu'on voit bien qu'elles disent le
texte aux prompteur donc le texte
prompteur il savait les organisateurs de
la cérémonie démoliaire savait qu'elle
avoir deux personnes de la CGT qui
allaient interpeller la ministre et ils
l'ont donné le texte donc la ministre
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle a dit bon
bah vous me préparer un micro croyez que
le micro il arrive comme ça avec un
micro qui arrive comme ça c'est c'est
magouille et compagnie le micro nous ici
on est en direct pour avoir un micro
c'est une demi-heure
là-bas il y a un bien à la ministre de
parler il y a un micro tiens il est sous
son cycle voilà le micro il y a donc il
y a le mec qui lui donne le micro il
attendait en plus vous avez vu il
attendait dans le on voyait il est dans
l'allée le gars et on voit qu'il va lui
donner donc qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait
elle avait elle a
elle a travaillé la phrase de Gérard
Philipe elle a dit oui c'était pour ça
donc tout était préparé elle a préparé
son texte voilà ils l'ont filé le texte
en fait les organisateurs ils ont filé
le test le texte à la ministre le texte
est de personnes de la CGT et elle a
préparé sa réponse notamment la citation
de Gérard Philipe de 1957 ils disent
donc elle a dit a été voir pourquoi ils
avaient dit ça donc ils l'ont préparé un
micro en salle comme je vous l'ai dit et
les téléspectateurs comme on dit là
doivent savoir que tout était orchestré
en fait tout était du mytho voilà CGT
mais pour la ministre exactement
vous nous donnez le texte et on va le
mettre au prompteur
c'était le piège parce qu'ils ont ils
l'ont donné à la ministre et à la mini
si on dit voilà ce qui va se dire ce qui
va se dire ce soir mais moi je vois pas
où est le problème en fait
j'aurais préféré que je trouve ça bien
qu'elle réponde vous vous trouvez pas
vos premiers
comme ça on arrête pas de dire que les
ministres pas je préfère qu'elle réponde
malgré tout moi j'étais content
aux gens que c'est une réponse spontanée
effectivement
Gérard Philipe 1955
mais c'est incroyable Géraldine
c'est-à-dire que on bidonne un truc et
la ministre des semblant d'être spontané
et c'est tout le téléspectateur les
choses les téléspectateurs qui sont
dupés alors que tout était préparé mais
c'est scénarisé quand je les vois partir
quand il y a des casseroles là dis on a
vu sur les extraits d'avant il se noble
les gens ils rigolent il leur parle pas
il marche comme si les gens n'existaient
pas le mec il demande des trucs sur les
AEH et il y a pas les moyens quand on
interpelle le musée d'éducation il
répond pas là moi j'étais content moi
m'avait cassé mon rêve parce que j'étais
content je me suis voilà à la courage il
y a on l'interpellé elle a le courage
elle s'éveille et là maintenant que tu
me dis que c'est un fait que tu me dis
que tout était préparé bah ça me dégoûte
c'est pas un fake parce que
tu as préparé
tais-toi mon chéri quand on parle tu
laisses les autres parler de la
politique
de la politique ça veut dire que c'est
de la triche vous foutez de la gueule
des Français triste parce qu'elle a déjà
la question
je veux que quand on leur parle dans la
rue avec les casseroles qu'ils aillent
parler aux Français comme elles se lever
là elle a fait la fièvre dans les dans
les dans les fauteuils rouges bien
maintenant bien enfermé entre eux là ça
se lève et ça prend le micro parle aux
gens quand ils viennent te voir dans la
rue avec des casseroles va leur parler
sans texte sans qu'on dise qu'il doit
dire réponse réponse gratuite
[Applaudissements]
le souci c'est que tu peux même te dire
encore pire tu peux aller plus loin tu
peux dire c'est même pas elle qui l'a
écrit ça répond pas monsieur
c'est là où le fait que nous pose
problème ah oui c'est que c'est pas
spontané et c'est pas une réponse bah si
c'est un fake parce que tu te préparer
un petit c'est un mec qui lui a écrit à
sa place j'appelle ça du fake
pourquoi c'est un fake c'est comme si tu
avais une interro frère on donne les
réponses ou c'est tout pour ça
elle avait rendez-vous avec les mecs de
la CGT trois fois ils sont pas venus moi
piège pour les téléspectateurs on leur
fait croire que c'est spontané bien sûr
et c'est un piège pour les deux filles
de la CGT c'est comme si tu faisais avec
un débat avec quelqu'un et qu'on se crée
on me donne les arguments de l'autre
pour que tu mettes les Bastos c'est pas
faire du tout et en plus et en plus dans
la séquence elle ressort gagnant du truc
parce que les deux femmes elles se
refait à pleuvoir c'est à se demander si
les a plus ce qui était lancés
et elle se fait siffler au début et
merci à challenge de m'avoir donné les
infos oui et là où c'est encore plus
hypocrite c'est qu'il faut pas être dupe
les organisateurs des Molières sont très
proches du pouvoir exactement Emmanuel
Macron à vous donc du ministère donc du
coup c'est une opération de propagande
politique organisé par les gouvernements
sur une chaîne publique sur le dos
définit l'article de challenge jeudi
c'est exactement ce qu'il a là c'est
dégueulasse franchement là c'est
impossible on peut pas faire ça elle
remet des vérités en place aujourd'hui
excuse-moi les les artistes ils ont en
France des chances des chances inouïes
par rapport à d'autres pays il y a plein
d'avantages pendant le covid ils ont été
préparés puissance militaires
ils ont eu je sais pas combien d'aides
donc non je suis désolé
même si elle l'a préparé et bah ce
qu'elle dit c'est juste et je m'en fous
qu'elle avait préparé parce que dans
plein d'interventions comme ça parfois
tu prépares parce que tu dis c'est pas
si choquant mais c'est tu mens au
téléspectateurs c'est un mensongement
vous êtes malade laisse-le parler vous
êtes complètement malade c'est une
opération d'orchestrer de bout en bout
et vous vous dites c'est merveilleux
alors la parole du coup du gouvernement
qu'est-ce qu'il dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'espérais que vous m'oubliez non alors
je vais vous dire une chose hier soir
moi j'ai vu la scène j'ai trouvé
formidable je lui ai envoyé un mot je
lui ai dit tu as été formidable
elle a été formidable maintenant le côté
préparé ou pas préparé je vais vous dire
sa réponse elle était quand même très
efficace et quand elle dit que les
syndicats ont refusé trois quatre fois
les rendez-vous et encore cette semaine
toi tu es toujours contre les syndicats
tu es toujours mais non j'ai jamais été
contre les syndicats du côté du
gouvernement mais pas du tout qui me
présenter comme ça à chaque fois tu veux
toujours aller manger tes petits fours
non on y va pas justement mais Bernard
c'est un petit four ce weekend quelque
part non plus ça doit être j'ai pas
besoin d'aller les Français
non plus je te dis bah dis la vérité je
vous dis la vérité mais que ça a été
préparé tu trouves pas ça ouf alors ça
je savais pas votre histoire maintenant
que tu le sais et ben ça change rien
elle a été bonne quand même parce que
pendant pendant le pendant le magnéto il
m'a dit tu es sûr de ça ouais parce que
je trouve ça un peu gênant le côté mais
bien sûr que c'est un peu gênant mais
maintenant sa réponse elle était très
efficace
là tu vas manger tous les vidéos
il y aura pas de mini ça tu vas le
manger comme ça
non je l'ai trouvé un texto donc ça veut
dire que tu la connais bien sûr que je
la connais bah donc tu es obligé de je
suis obligé de rien du tout un peu quand
même est-ce que j'ai balancé sur elle
quand elle s'est présentée vous faites
pas la part des choses vous quand j'ai
râler quand elle était influencée
pas du tout j'ai dit que quand elle est
allé voir et danser avec Rihanna
Fondation Louis Vuitton j'ai trouvé que
c'était nul c'est du tout et là hier
soir j'ai trouvé très bonne et je vous
emmerde donc
non
moi je suis pas la ministre je te le dis
moi tu vois moi je vais pas manger des
petits fours avec les gars tout ça avec
toi tout ça moi tu m'as dit je suis pas
dans une 50 ministres moi moi est-ce que
tu m'as déjà vu moi aller manger un
petit four avec quelqu'un ou quelque
chose comme jamais dans une soirée
arrête arrête pas tu es dans toutes les
soirées ah oui ah bien sûr c'est normal
on a vu les dernières pages de gala
frère et de voici
pour le travail j'ai côtoyé oui Olivier
Véran parce qu'on a fait une émission
ensemble Gérald Darmanin et je l'ai
toujours dit je vais toujours Darmanin
il est venu et il m'a fait venir oui
après le reste c'est pas mes amis Rimal
doux que c'était mes amis bah si tu as
ton portable et tu as été supérieur
des gens que je connais pas
j'ai dit je la connais je lui ai envoyé
un mot très brillante maintenant avec
votre histoire votre histoire c'est vrai
que c'est un peu gênant
sa réponse était quand même très bonne
mais juste à l'arrivée tu suces qui les
deux là il est en double
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]